اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
واشنطن تستعد لتزويد كييف بسلاح بعيد
المدى للمره الاولى قادره على استهداف
العمق الروسي
نتنياهو يقر بعمليات ضد معامله تطوير
الاسلحه داخل ايران ولا يستبعد استخدام
القوه
المرصد يقول لان مليشيات ايران وحزب الله
تستنفر على حدود سوريا ولبنان ومحيط دمشق
هجوم بثمانيه صواريخ يستهدف قاعده تركيه
بمحافظه نينوى العراقيه ولا انباء عن
خسائر بشريه
اهلا بكم تعدوا الولايات المتحده مساعدات
عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا تتضمن اسلحه
النوعيه يمكنها ضرب اهداف عسكريه روسيه
قيمه الحزوه الجديده تبلغ قيمتها مليارين
و 200 مليون دولار ومن المتوقع ان تضم
صواريخ بعيده المدى للمره الاولى ومن
المقرر الاعلان عنها هذا الاسبوع على ان
تشمل ايضا معدات دعم لانظمه الدفاع الجوي
باتريوت ودخل الى دقيقه التوجيه والصواريخ
للدبابات وقال مسؤول الامريكي انه من
المرجح شراء الصواريخ يبلغ مداها 150 كلم
وتساعد اوكرانيا بطبيعه الحال على ضرب
اهداف بعيده المنال وبدوره اكد الرئيس
الاوكراني فولتمي اكد انك بشركائها تعمل
على افشال ما سماها محاوله روسيا للانتقام
من بلاده موضحا ان هذا الهدف له الاولويه
ماشي قوتنا الدفاعيه والامنيه وشركاؤنا
نحن جميعا نعمل ليس فقط لضمان عدم انتصار
روسيا في ساحه المعركه فحسب بل حتى تخسر
في محاولتها للانتقام وهو الامل الاخير
للعدوان
حتى الان حول رغبه واشنطن بتزويد بصواريخ
او اسلحه بعيده المدى
مرحبا فاطمه حقيقه رئيس الاستخبارات
الخارجيه الروسيه
تحدث صباح اليوم ان الغرب يقوم بتوزيع
وزياده نطاق الاسلحه التي يتم ارسالها الى
اوكرانيا من اجل محاربه روسيا حتى اخر
اوكراني طبعا هو تحدث عن ان الغرب وحلف
النت وبالتحديد يرفع الثقه في الرهان
لهزيمه روسيا ولكن هذا لن يحدث
من ارسال صواريخ بعيده المدى الى اوكرانيا
كما تعتبر موسكو سيكون بمثابه مشاركه
مباشره
بان هذه الاسلحه او مطالب اوكرانيا
بالحصول على صواريخ بعيده المدى هو بمثابه
ايضا للمشاركه في هذه الحرب ضد روسيا ولكن
روسيا مرارا تاكدت انها ستقوم بقصف اي
شحنه عسكريه ستصل من الخارج وان هذا لن
يؤثر على مسار العمليه العسكريه لان روسيا
ستذهب حتى النهايه وتحقق جميع الاهداف كما
حدث مرارا وتكرار مرارا بتكرارا الكرملين
والمسؤولين الروس فاطمه طيب كاتيا همم
يعني في الاسابيع الماضيه راينا موسكو
تنشر اسلحه مضاده على المباني المهمه في
العاصمه الروسيه وتحدثت ايضا عن انها
قادره على الردع دبابات ليوبارد 2 همم هذه
المضادات التي نشرتها هل هي ربما هل من
معلومات ربما اذا كانت هي قادره على اي
هجوم مباشر على موسكو
صحيح فاطمه بنت صباح الخبراء العسكريين
كانوا قد تحدثوا ووسائل عالميه روسيه ايضا
تحدثت عن ان المضادات الصواريخ الروسيه هي
او نظام الدفاع الصاروخي الروسي هو قادر
على
صد هذه الصواريخ بعيده المدى التي ستحصل
عليها اوكرانيا وبالتاليا حتى الان لا
يوجد تخوف من في حال حصلت اوكرانيا على
هذه الصواريخ بان تقوم باسقاطها انظمه
الدفاع الجوي الروسيه بالاضافه لذلك
المقاتلات ايضا التي ستحصل عليها اوكرانيا
همم اول روسيا توسيطر على جميع همم على
المجال الجوي الاوكراني بشكل كامل وثانيا
على جميع المطارات الاوكرانيه وبالتالي
سيكون هناك صعوبه تقنيه بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين ليه استخدام هذه النقطات التي
ستحصل عليها او في حال حصلت عليها في وقت
لاحد فاطمه طيب كانت نتحدث قليلا
الميدانيه ما اخر الانباء الوارده لديك
حول التقدم الميداني الذي تفرزه القوات
ميرسي حسب الانباء
حقيقه منذ قليل
في اطار تقدم القوات وبالتحديد هنا ايضا
قوات الانفصاليه وقوات همم
فاتنر ايضا اقوات بادنر الخاصه هناك تطبيق
لباخبط من ثلاث جهات ولكن لم يتم السيطره
عليها بعد بالاضافه الى ذلك ان هناك طبعا
حديث يوم امس عن اتقدم في منطقه زابارجي
ايضا همم السيطره على عده مناطق في منطقه
زابارويا كما تحدثت ايضا القوات
الانفصاليه يوم امس لذلك نحن نشهد الان
نتقدم للقوات الروسيه والانفصاليه
بالاضافه لقوات
روسيا تقول انها خلال الفتره القادمه
ستتحاول السيطره على كافل كافه اراضي
دنياك
بشكل كامل على دوم بس بعد ان سيطرت على
90% ايضا واضح اراضي شكرا لك من موسكو
مراسله العربيه
اعلنا منسق لاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن الوطني الامريكي جون كربي اعلن عن
تراقب البيت الابيض طرحه ازمه اوكرانيا
وروسيا على طاوله المباحثات الصينيه
الامريكيه وذلك خلال زياره وزير الخارجيه
عن سيليب لانكن الى بكين الاسبوع المقبل
وقد حذرت واشنطن بكين مسبقا من تقديم
الدعم لروسيا في تجاوز العقوبات او تقديم
منتجات عسكريه وكانت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه نشرت مشاهدينا صورا لتدريب
اطقم الدبابات الاوكرانيه على دبابات
تشالنجر 2 والتي ستقدمها المملكه المتحده
لمساعده القوات الاكرانيه
[موسيقى]
وقطعت دنيتك مشاهدينا تعاني من شح المياه
منذ مطلع العام الماضي تزامنا ما عندي لا
على الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث يتهموا سكانها
اوكرانيا بقطع الماء عن تلك المناطق
المواليه لروسيا عقابا لهم فيما يدفع
الجيش الروسي بكل قوه لبست نفوده على
المناطق الشماليه في المقاطعه مثل مدينه
باخمود والتي تحجز المياه العذبه خلفا في
نهر سفيرسكي دونيتس
منذ انطلاق الاعمال العسكريه والمواطنون
في مقاطعه دانيتك يسعون لتقنين استخدام
المياه التي يصعب الحصول عليها وان كانت
غير صالحه للشرب
وهكذا نحصل على المياه مره كل ثلاثه ايام
بات هذا المشهد معتادا عند سكان مدينه بل
والمقاطعه باكملها بعد ان اصبحت المياه
تضخ ساعتين كل ثلاثه ايام
للمنطقه وليس للمنازل والبيوت
ومع دخول فصل الشتاء اصبحت المياه اكثر
شحا وباتت الحاجه لحل ازمه المياه ملحه
وسط سعي السلطات المحليه لايصالها عبر
انابيبها من نهر الدون في مدينه رستوف
الروسيه الاقرب لدانياتك
تضخ المياه لساعات محدوده منذ شهر يوليو
والان يعملون على ايصال المياه لنا عندما
يحررون تلك المناطق فقط سوف تدخل لنا
المياه فنهر سيفيرسكي دونيتس يمر من
خاركيف ثم من سلافيان ثم يصل الينا ويصعد
جيش الروسي للسيطره على المدن الشماليه من
من اجل الوصول الى مصادر المياه العذبه في
حوض دمباز خلف مدن باخ موت وكراميتورسك
وصله فيانس والتي يسيطر عليها الجيش
الاوكراني ما زالت المياه شحيحه في مقاطعه
دانيسك ذلك بعد منع امداداتها من قبل
القوات الروسيه التي تسيطر على مدينه
سلابيانس في المنطقه الشماليه من المقاطعه
بينما تحوي هذه المدينه ابار تحليه المياه
القائمه على نهر
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاخضر
تستمر وفيها
عقوبات امريكيه تستهدف ايران لتقييد ارسال
الطائرات المسوره الى روسيا
احييكم من جديد اعلن رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ان التهديد
باستخدام القوه قد يكون العام الوحيد
القادر على وقف برنامج ايران النووي واشار
خلال مقابله مع قناه سي ان ان الى ان
اعتقاده ان الايرانيين لا يريدون الحرب
لانهم سيخسرون ويتعاملون مع هذا بشكل حذر
للغايه واقرر نتنياه بشن عمليات ضد تطويل
اسلحه معينه في ايران لكنه رفضت تعليق على
الادعاء بان اسرائيل كانت وراءه هجوم
مسيرات في مدينه اصفهان قبل ايام وحول ذلك
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه زياد حلبي من
القدس اهلا بك معنا زياد اذا تصريحات لا
فيتال نتانياه حول ضربات الاخيره على
ايران ما ابرز ما اتى في تصريحاته زياد
عمليه نتنياهو اعطى مقابله مدتها ساعه
كامله لقناه سي ان الامريكيه في ضمنها سئل
عن الضربات في اصفهان قال انه لا يتطرق
الى عمل اسرائيلي بعينه ولكنه لفت الى انه
ان ان ان اسرائيل تعمل ضد سلاح ايرانيا
تستخدمه عمليا ايران في اوكرانيا طبعا لا
يحتاج الامر الى الكثير من التفكير لمعرفه
انه سلاح المسيررات التي تعطيها لروسيا
فتستخدمها الاخيره في اوكرانيا بهذا
المعنى يقر بان عمليه اسرائيل تضرب سلاح
مسيرات الايراني لانه يستخدم في روسيا هذا
يغمز من هذه القناه لامريكا والغرب التي
عمليا همم ما تزال غاضبه من اسرائيل بسبب
موقفها غير الحاسمه والواضح لصالح الغرب
واوكرانيا والتعامل والتعاطي بوتين وروسيا
طوال الوقت هذا باعتقاد كان لافتا جدا في
هذا التصريح طبعا قال ايضا وربما بذلك يرد
على التسريبات الامريكيه السريعه كالبرق
هذه المره التي كانت بعد ضربه اسفاه
واسفهان عفوا وضربات الاخرى قال ان دائما
عندما يكون انفجار في الشرق الاوسط تتهموا
اسرائيل احيانا تكون هي واحيانا لا تكون
هي في اشاره ربما الى ان الامر قد يكون من
تنفيذ
السياحيه او الامريكيين او جهات اخرى ايا
كان همم الواضح بان نتنياهو عمليا يحاول
ان يحث اداره على توفير عمليه همم همم
خيار عسكري دي مصداقيه كما تسميه اسرائيل
يوضع على الطاوله امام ايران اساسا ليس
لاستخدامه بقدر ما ردعها عن الاستمرار
تجاه التخصيب 90% اي ال همم الذهاب تجاه
القنبله النوويه
العسكريا اذا الى ماذا تشير في ظل كل هذه
المعلومات زياد الى ماذا تشير الانباء او
تتحدث الصحف في الداخل هل هناك توافق
امريكي اسرائيلي حول الضربه الاخيره على
ايران او حتى التعامل العسكري معها ام
هناك مازال خلاف حول ذلك
لا الواضح في الفتره الاخيره على الاقل من
خلال المناورات العسكريه المشتركه التي
حاكت
لا مفاجاه في الامر ضرب منشات نوويه في
ايران وبعدها حجيج من المسؤولين
الامريكيين يتزامن مع ضربات في عمق ايران
هذا قد كانها رساله بانها تمت تنسيقا
مشتركا بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
تجاه العمل العسكري ضد المشروع النووي
الايراني ربما هذا هو التهديد لايران في
هذه الجزئيه لكن فيما يتصل بالضربه نفسها
الواضح للاسرائيليين وراينا نتنياهو يتحدث
عن ذلك مرات عده بان اسرائيل قد تضطر
وحدها في مرحله ما بدون امريكا ان تقوم
بهذه الضربه وهذا يغير دراماتيكيا النتائج
لهذه الضربه وامكان يعني العمل على
تبعاتها في المنطقه والعالم ولهذا هناك
دائما حرب تسريبات وغ من حكومه نتنياهو
تحديدا الذي يتهم الامريكيين بانهم يسربون
الاخبار حول العمل العسكري الاسرائيلي ضد
ايران وانهم قد يسربون حتى اذا لو اطلعتم
اسرائيل انا ستقوم بعد اسبوع مثلا بضرب
المنشات النوويه جد ذلك سريعا في الوشنطن
بوست بهدف احباط هذه العمليه وفي المقلب
اخر امريكا تشك بان تل ابيب ستفاجئها في
ضربه في مرحله حتى لو لم تكن جايزه هذه
ضربه بقرار الاسرائيليه شكرا لك من القدس
مراسل العربيه زياد حلبي
من التصعيد الايراني الاسرائيلي الى
عقوبات واشنطن ضد طهران حيث اعلنت وزاره
التجاره الامريكيه فرض قيود تجاريه جديده
على سبعه كيانات ايرانيه بسبب انتاجها
طائرات مسيره واستخدمتها في روسيا ضد
اوكرانيا وان الشركات والمنظمات الايرانيه
وضعت على قائمه الرقابه على الصادرات
الامريكيه تتضمن كيانات منخرطه في انشطه
تهدد الامن القومي والسياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه الكيانات الايرانيه تضم الشركه
لتصنيع محركات الطائرات والقوه الجويه
التابعه للحراس الثوري الايراني ومعها
منظمه الجهاد للاكتفاء الذاتي بالاضافه
الى شركه
بارافار باريس وشركه القدس لصناعه الطيران
وشاهد لصناعه الطيران كذلك فيما قالت
ايران ان العقوبات لن تؤثر على قدره طيران
في انتاج الطائرات التي تسمى محليا بشكل
كامل
الخارجيه الاستراليه مشاهدينا على نت فرض
عقوبات على 16 مسؤولا ايرانيا بعضهم من
الحرس الثوري وكيان واحد لتورطهم في قمع
الاحتجاجات والتي تشهدها ايران منذ سبتمبر
الماضي وقالت الخارجيه الاستراليه في هذا
الشان ان الحكومه فرضت ايضا عقوبات اضافيه
على اربعه افراد واربعه كيانات في ايران
لمشاركتهم في انتاج وتوريد الطائرات
المسيره الى روسيا واستخدامها في الحرب ضد
اوكرانيا وفي سياق اخر اكد المبعوث
الامريكيه الخاص الى ايران روبرت مالي اكد
دعم الحقوق الاساسيه للشعب الايراني في
مواجهه النظام مشددا على ضروره مواجهه
سياسات النظام الايراني
للاستقرار في العالم
يمكننا ويجب علينا الدعم الحقوق الاساسيه
للشعب الايراني وفي نفس الوقت السعي وراء
مصالحنا الوطنيه في مواجهه سياسه ايران
الاستفزازيه والمزعزعه للاستقرار عملت
جميع اركان اداره بيض بشكل عاجل وقوي
لتعبئه المجتمع الدولي ومواجهه انتهاكات
حقوق الانسان التي يرتكبها النظام
الايراني
ادرجت ايران في اسفل الجدول مؤشر ما يعرف
بمدركات الفساد في العالم لعام 2022 الى
جانب دول مثل جينيا وبنغلادش وبحسب
التقرير احتلت ايران المرتبه 147 من بين
180 دوله واكدت المنظمه الشفافيه الدوليه
او منظمه الشفافيه الدوليه ان ايران لم
تحرز اي تقدم في مكافحه الفساد بما في ذلك
غسل الاموال والفساد السياسيه والاداري
سنوات الثلاثه الماضيه
مشاهدينا المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
افاد بان مليشيات ايران وحزب الله على
الحدود السوريه اللبنانيه ومحيط دمشق في
حاله تاهب واستنفار المرصد اضاف ان تلك
المليشيات تمنع الاقتراب من مقراتها
العسكريه وتخلي ابنيه سكنيه يقتنها
قياديها وتجمع سياراتهم في اماكن محدده في
ظل تعزيزات امنيه لمقرات تلك مليشيات على
الحدود السوريه اللبنانيه وعلى محيط دمشق
وحول ذلك ينضم الينا من القاهره مدير
المرسل السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد
الرحمن اهلا بك معنا سيد رامي اذا ما
اسباب هذا الارتباك والاستنفار في قيادي
يوميات ايران في محيط دمشق وفي سوريا
نعم صباح الخير على ما يبدا الامر مرتبط
بما حصل في البوكمال قبل يومين هذا الامر
اربك يعني حزب الله اربك جماعه الايرانيه
في دمشق ومحيطها عند الحدود السوريه
اللبنانيه وايضا في مقاراتهم ان تكون
البيئه فاضله حقيقه الامر لهذا هذه
التنظيمات العامله في سوريا في السيده
زينب على سبيل المثال جرى تحصين المقرات
امنيا ابعاد اي من هو غير مرتبط بحزب الله
عن محيط هذه المقرات على ما يبدو ايضا
نجارها تبديل المقرات لهذه المنشات كوفا
من خلقني وليس من ضربات اسرائيليه لان
الخلق اصعب عليهن من عمليه الضربات
الاسرائيليه وفي مناطق كانوا يعتقدونها
بانها امنه بشكل كامل لهم وايضا بعين نقول
بان خبر بعد قليل في المنصف 11 عنصرا من
المنشات الجنسيه السوريه جرى اعتقالهم من
قبل حزب الله اللبناني في مدينه الميادين
والبوكمال بعد ضرب التي استهدفت الصهاريج
او عفوا الشاحنات القادره من ايران والتي
كان من المستوى بانها سريه وامنه بشكل
كامل ضمن قافله مواد غذائيه جرى استهدافها
عند الحدود ذكرنا قبل يومين هذا الامر
مرتبط بالتداعيات الامنيه لهذا الامر
وخوفا من وجود عملاء بشكل كبير جدا داخل
هذه الميليشيات او في محيط هذه الميليشيات
حتى من عناصر القوات النظام الذين من
المفترض بانهم مقربين من حزب الله ومقربين
من ميليشيات ايران في
تم اعتقالهم سيد رامي على ضمن هذه
الخروقات التي تتحدث عنها يعني خوفا من
انهم عملاء لاسرائيل
بشكل قطيول او للتحالف الدولي ليس اسرائيل
فقط او للتحالف الدولي جرى اعتقالهم في
مدينتي الحكماء والميادين من العاملين
السوريين مع هذه المنشيهات لانه هناك
مخاوف حقيقيه مستمره من قبل حزب الله رغم
الاحتياطات الامنيه الكامله من عمليات
القلق الامني لهذا الحزب او لمنشيات ايران
من السعوديه ولكن اعتقد بان خلق هو اكبر
من لبنان بدنا اللبنانيين او الايرانيين
اكثر من السوريين لان السوريين ليس لديهم
مناصب قياديه دخل هذه الاشياء
التي تتخوف منها مليشيات ايران في الحدود
السوريه اللبنانيه ومحيط دمشق هل هناك
تخوف من ربما ضربات على مناطق ايران في
سوريا
ولذلك الامر لاعاده التموضع والاستغفار هو
تحدثنا عن دمشق وريفها تحدثنا عن الحدود
السوريه اللبنانيه وايضا في منطقه الباديه
السوريه هناك ايضا لاعاده تموت عدديهم عده
مقرات يتنقلون بها كي يكون هناك عمليه
تمويه خوفا من الاستدابات الاسرائيليه او
استهداف الطائرات المجهوله التي لا تعلم
اذا ما كانت تابعه للتحالف الدوري
هل شهدته الميليشيات الايرانيه من قبل ان
هذا يعني المره الاولى التي يحدث فيها
اعاده التموضع هذا والارتباك الذي نسمعه
سابقا في الميادين على المثال في بعض
النقاط ولكن ليس في حاله الاستغفار
الانديه الكبيره الامر الذي حصل خلال
ساعات الثمانيه واربعين الفائته من الديار
الصور والصور الحدود السوريه اللبنانيه ان
هناك كبير داخل هذه المنشات وانا اركز
بانها
خرجت القاهره العراق
سوريات لو لم يكن هناك خرج كبير جدا لما
تمكنت الجهه او الطائرات المجهوله من
استهداف شاحنات بعينها ادى تدميرها وايضا
تدمير الاسلحه او الذخيره او لا نعلم ما
اذا كان في داخلها ثم من قبل الطائرات
المجهوله شكرا لك من القاهره مدير المرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن
استهدفت ثمانيه صواريخ كانت تركيا شرق
محافظه نينوى العراقيه في شمال البلاد
وحتى اللحظه لم تتبين اي وجهه او تتمنى اي
وجيها هذا الاستهداف وتقيم انقر نحو
اربعين نقطه وقاعده عسكريه مشاهدينا في
شمال العراق قرب حدودها حيث تطارد منذ
اكثر من 25 عاما مقاتلي حزب العمال
الكردستاني والذي تصنفه انقر وحلفاءها
الغربيون منظمه ارهابيه ينضموا الينا من
اربيل مراسل العربيه احمد الحمداني اهلا
بك معنا احمد اذا استهداف ليس بالاول لهذه
القاعده العسكريه ما تفاصيل هذا الاستهداف
حتى الان وهل من اصابات داخل القاعده بما
انه صاروخان حتى الان همم يعني وقعاه داخل
القاعده العسكريه
[موسيقى]
بالفعل صاروخان همم وقع داخل القاعده وسته
في محيط القاعده والخبر التحديث الخبر وفي
خبر عاجل لان ما يعرف بفصيل لواء احرار
العراق هو من تبنى هذا الهجوم على قاعده
الزليكان التركيه وطبعا كان يعرف هذا
الفصيل قبل هذا المره كانوا يعرف بالواء
احرار سنجار وهذه المره همم
ظهر فصيل جديد ولكن بالحقيقه هو نفس
الفصيل على ما يبدو بحسب مصادر هو الذي
استهدف قاعده الزنكان وتوعد التواجد
التركي في العراق بالتواصل بتواصل ضربات
والهجمات وقال انهم استهدفوا في همم ب 20
صاروخ قرارات نوع اغراض عيار 122 ملم
القاعده التركيه لم يكن لم يوضح بيان
التبني او اي جهه مكان
انطلاق الصواريخ الا ان الثابت ان مكان
انطلاق الصواريخ هي من محافظه نينوى
تحديدا المناطق القريبه من بعشيقه وهي
طبعا تعرف على ما يبدا تعرف بالسهل نينوى
وهي على غرار المرات الفائته بحسب مصادر
طبعا بالتالي فان احرار العراق ويحمل همم
اشاره او يحمل علامه همم قريبه من علامه
حزب الله العراقي همم في شعار هذا هذا
الفصيل او هذا الذي يعرف باللواء احرار
العراق بالتالي فان هو اشارات ودلالات على
ان نفس ال- نفس الطريقه وبنفس الاماكن
وبنفس الاسلوب الذي كانت همم كان استاذ
هذا
المعسكر وهو فصيل همم قوامه من من البكاء
التركيه المعارضه التركيه وايضا من
المليشيات انه موالي
تنا قبل قليل احمد ذكرت لي بان له تصريحات
حتى الان حول هذا الحدود ولكن ماذا عن
الان بعد هذا التبني من قبل فصيل لواء
احرار العراق هل من تصريحات من مسؤولين من
بغداد او حتى اربيل خرجت
حتى الان يبدو ان الوقت لا يزال ما زال
مبكرا في التصريحات والمواقف ولكن همم حتى
الان لم تخرج اي تصريحات واي مواقف لا من
اربيل ولا من بغداد على على هذا على هذا
الهجوم الصاروخي وايضا من تركيا او على
اقل تقدير من سفارتها ببغداد او قنصليه في
الموصل او في همم في اربيل لم يكن هناك اي
مواقف
وليبدوا ان هناك همم على ما يبدو هناك
اتصالات ما بين الجانب التركي والجانب
العراقي في هذا الموضوع وهمم لم
تتسرب لدينا اي معلومات عن هذه الاتصالات
بالعاده يكون هناك اتصالات ما بين الجانب
التركي والجانب العراقي سواء كان في اربيل
او في بغداد شكرا لك من اربيل مراسل
العربيه احمد الحمداني
الى العراق حيث قال رئيس الحكومه العراقيه
محمد شيعه السوداني ان ملايين الدولارات
تهرب بشكل يومي الى خارج البلاد وبفواتير
مزوره موضحا اكتشاف الامر بعد ما تم الزام
الجميع باجراء التحويلات عبر منصه سويفت
الى الالكترونيه والتي تتيح للبنك المركزي
الامريكي المراقبه في وقت خسرت العمره
المحليه اكثر من 10% من قيمتها ما ادى الى
موجه تظاهرات متفرقه احتجاجا على تراجع
القدره الشرائيه للمواطنين
من العراق الى ليبيا حيث تسع وزاره
الداخليه بحكومه الوحده في الليبيه فرض
سيطرتها واثبات وجودها في العاصمه كخطوه
اولى قبل الانتقال الى مديريات فوق طرابلس
ومن ثم الى باقي المدن في ظل انتشار
السلاح وسيطره بعض التشكيلات على الاحياء
وعلى المدن
في طرابلس اعلنتها وزاره الداخليه بحكومه
الوحده الوطنيه من خلال نشر تمركزات نمليه
للاجهزه النظاميه التابعه للدوله على مدار
الساعه في كل شوارع العاصمه بعد دعم مراكز
الشرطه ومكونات الوزاره
التي تجعلهم قادرين على مواجهه اي خروقات
امنيه في ظل انتشار السلاح في البلاد
ليه
الشارع العام
ولهذا يعني نظره معالي الوزير
كافيه لاعطاء نتائج سريعه خصوصا مع وجود
ما يقارب 20 مليون قطعه سلاح في البلاد
بحسب تقديرات اعلاميه انا اعتقد انه
معالجه الملف الامنيات الامنيه التي تحدث
بين حين والاخر في العاصمه طراب بس اكبر
بكثير ما انتم تعالجه خطه امنيه تطلقها
وزاره الداخليه الكثير يعني يصف انه الفرق
او الخروقات الامنيه اسبابها سياسيه
المواطنون يرحبون بمثل هذه العمليات كونها
تدعم وجهها الى فرض القانوني والتقليل من
سطوه التشكيلات المسلحه
الانتشار الامني توا الفتره هذه شو في 18
ايام تحسن الله الله يبارك
واقع وان شاء الله الافضل للافضل فيه
الناس
كثير عادي
البوابه عاديه
في اول خمسه ايام من تنفيذ الخطه تم ضبط
اكثر من 500 سياره مجهوله الهويه من بينها
مركبات تابعه لمجموعه مسلحه خطط امنيه
جديده تحاول الداخليه تنفيذها لضبط الامن
داخل العاصمه وفرض هيبه الدوله وكبه
اجتماعي التشكيلات المسلحه فيما يعمل سكان
العاصمه ان تنجح هذه الخطوات في خفض
معدلات الجريمه وضبط الامن داخل المدينه
منير الاشهب طرابلس العربيه
من سطوه التشكيلات
المسلحه في ليبيا الى الانتخابات
التشريعيه في تونس والتي افضت الى
انتخابات 154 نائبا من اصل 161 سيشكلون
برلمان تونس الجديد وبعد اعلان هيئه
الانتخابات عن النتائج الاوليه للانتخابات
تضاربت ردود الفعل حولها بين
مؤيد ورافض في وقتنا اعتبر الرئيس سعيد ان
نسبه العزوف تعكس رفضه التونسيين للبرلمان
بشكله القديم
مئه واربعه وخمسون نائبا من اصل 201
سيشكلون برلمانات تونس الجديد بعد استكمال
الاستحقاق التشريعي الاول منذ اعلان
الاجراءات الاستثنائيه في البلاد على ان
يتم ذلك طبقا للاجراءات القضائيه
والقانونيه
سجلنا قيام تصويت
8950002 ناخذ تونسي توجهه الى صناديق
الاقتراع يوم 29 جانفي والنسبه العامه كما
قلت الاقبال بصفه رسميه ونهائيه هي 11 فصل
40% ورقم الاخير على طبيعته الانتخابات
التشريعيه وما حف بها من ظروف سياسيه الا
ان منظمات المجتمع المدني المحليه
والدوليه القارات بانها كانت مزيحه
جدا خاصه
لهذه الانتخابات شرعيه موجوده اللي هي
القانون لكن المشروعيه في اغلب الدول لما
نشوف لم يتجاوزوا من 5.6% من الجسم
الانتخابي وفور اعلاني النتائجيه خرجت قوى
المعارضه فيما عوده استثمارا سياسيا
لتطالب الرئيس سعيد بالتنحي او على الاقل
بادخال تعديلات سياسيه كبيره على برنامجه
لا يتاخر الرد من سعيد ليعلنا نهايه
المنظومه القديمه ملوحا بالمحاسبه
تونس لتونسيين والتونسي
فيها من يشاء كما يشاء
وسيتحمل هؤلاء المسؤوليه خيانتهم العظمى
لتونس قوس برلمان 2019 اغلق نهائيا وان
السيد راشد الغنوشي لم يعد بتلك الحسنه
التي يحذر بهذاك رئيس برلمان ليس داخليا
فقد حزم الامر ولكن خارجيا
وينتظر هنا عقاد البرلماني الجديد منتصف
شهر مارس اذار المقبل على اقصى تقدير وعلى
راسي اولوياته الملفات الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه
وبعدما بحث صناديق الاقتراعي باسرارها
وتوضحت ملامح البرلمان الجديده تتوجه
الانظار نحو مالات الازمه المركبه وافاق
حلها مع تمدرس كل طرف بموقفه بما يبقي
الوضع مفتوحا على اكثر من احتمال وليد
عبدالله العربيه
تونس
تتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل بريطانيا تتاهب
لاضخم اضراب العماليين ومخاوف من تفشي
فوضى عارمه في المنشات والخدمات
احييكم من جديد
مليونان و 800 الف تظاهر بالامس مشاهدينا
في فرنسا وذلك احتجاجا على رفع سن التقاعد
وفق النقابات العماليه التظاهرات شهدت
مواجهات محدوده بين المتظاهرين والشرطه
والمعارضه اليسريه تتواعد الحكومه بتحركات
جديده الاسبوع المقبل
اضراب كبير يشل فرنسا محطه القطارات
والمترو هذه تكاد تخلو من المسافرين لان
قطع النقل هو ابرز القطاعات التي تشارك في
هذا الاضراب بالاضافه الى قطاعات التعليم
والسكك الحديديه والطاقه معطل انتاج
الكهربائي واوقف عمليه نقل الوقود من
المصافي الى المحطات لكن مشهد خلو وسائل
النقل من المسافرين والمؤسسات من الموظفين
كان مختلفا جدا في الخارج
بها الفرنسيون الى الشارع للاحتجاج على
رفع سن التقاعد وايضا ارتفاع الاسعار وترد
الاوضاع المعيشيه هي موجه ثانيه من اصل
ثلاث موجات للاضراب والتظاهر دعت اليها 8
نقابات والاحزاب اليسا مجتمعه ما يضع
الرئيس الفرنسي امام تحدي جديد مع الشارع
يقول الرجل الاول في الحزب الاشتراكي انهم
سيكملونه حتى النهايه
تحرك ضخم جدا وهدى دليل على تشكل حركه
شعبيه لن تتوقف ستستمر هذه الحركه حتى
تتراجع الحكومه وتسحب هذا المشروع تظاهرات
الموجه الثانيه شهدت زياده في زخم
المشاركه وقالت النقابات ان نصف مليون نزل
الى شوارع العاصمه بين مقدرت الشرطه
اعدادهم بنحو
87.000.000 الاستخبارات الفرنسيه توقعت
مشاركه جماعات يساريه عنيفه صدقه التوقعات
ووقعت صدامات محدوده لكن سرعان ما عدا
الهدوء واستانف المتظاهرون تحركم
مياده
اخرى للتحرك لان الحكومه لا تنصت الى
الحركه الاجتماعيه في الشارع
اهتماما بالعدول عن هذا القانون وتقول
انها منفتحه على نقش بعض البنود لكن رفع
سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما ستظل مساله غير
قابله للنقاش فاتن دهوك العربيه باريس
الى الاضرابات التي تشهدها بريطانيا والتي
تستعد لمواجهه اضخم اضراب مشاهدينا اضراب
عمالي منذ اكثر من 10 سنوات
عن الذهاب الى اعمالهم هذه الاضطرابات
اعلنت عنها نقابه الخدمات العامه ونقابه
النقابه التجاريه انا حوالين 100,000 موظف
في الخدمه المدنيه سيضربون اليوم وذلك بعد
فشل محادثات مع الحكومه لانهاء نزاع بشان
الاجور والوظائف وشروط العمل اذا في
بريطانيا هناك خلاف حول الاجور وحول العمل
حول ايضا الكثير من نزاع بشان الاجور
والوظائف وشروط العمل كذلك هذا في
بريطانيا تحديدا ومن المتوقع ان يخرج اكثر
من نصف مليون بريطاني الى هذه التظاهرات
وهي الاكبر منذ 10 سنوات هناك مخاوف عده
من تعطل
وتعطل الخدمات في بريطانيا ولكن تاكيد ذلك
وحول المزيد عن ذلك من لندن تنضم الينا
مراسله العربيه عروب عبد الحق اهلا بك
معنا عروب اذا لنبدا بالجهات التي اعلنت
هذا الاضراب وطلبه بهذا الاضراب وما
الاسباب المذكوره حتى الان
مرحبا فاطمه يعني احدى هذه الجهات التي
اعلنت عن الاضراب اليوم سائقي القطارات
نحن الان امام محطه احدى ابرز المحطات هنا
في في لندن وكما ترون من خلفي هذه المحطه
مغلقه اليوم حتى على الشاشات الموجوده
امام هذه المحطه تقول بان القطارات خارج
الخدمه بسبب
اضراب الذي همم يعني هو من اكبر
الاضطرابات التي تشهدها بريطانيا منذ عام
2011 طبعا الابرز في هذه همم في في اضراب
اليوم بانه الاكثر تنسيقا ما بين النقابات
نحن نعلم بان هناك حوالي نصف مليون همم
عامل وموظف يضربون اليوم عن العمل في
مختلف القطاعات منهم مثلا موظفين في قطاع
الخدمه المدنيه يعني حوالي 100,000 عامل
في هذا في هذا القطاع في مختلف طبعا
الدوائر الحكوميه حوالي 123 دائره ووكاله
حكوميه تحت او ينصبون تحت قطاع الخدمه
المدنيه اياهم يضربون عن العمل اليوم ايضا
الجديد في اضرابات اليوم هو اضراب
المعلمين هو الاكبر منذ حوالي ثلاثه عقود
تتاثر حوالي همم 23 الف مدرسه اليوم بهذا
الاضراب يوجد اضراب حوالي 100.000 من
المعلمين وبالتالي سيؤثر هذا بشكل كبير
على الاهالي بشكل خاص الذين سيترون الى
عدم الذهاب الى العمل من اجل رعايه
الاطفال طبعا هناك اضرابات ايضا اخرى
اضرابات الحافلات سائقي الحافلات سائقين
قطارات كما ذكرنا 22,000 من سائقي
القطارات سيضربون اليوم عن العمل وبالتالي
هو اضراب كبير سيؤثر بشكل كبير على همم
على البلاد كما ذكر يعني رئيس ذكر يعني قد
تدعون الذي قال انه سيكون هناك هذا سيكون
يوم صعب على بريطانيا
هل هي فقط في العاصمه ام تنتشر في مدن
اخرى
طبعا الاضراب اليوم يعني يشمل انجلترا
ويشمل وينز ايضا ويشمل يعني مختلف المناطق
في في بريطانيا طبعا النقابات بشكل عام
تقول بان الموظفين باتوا غير قادرين على
تحمل اعباء المعيشه في بريطانيا كان هناك
تصريح لافته هذا الصباح من مسؤول في
النقابه قال بان 40,000 من الموظفين بشكل
عام يعتمدون على بنوك الطعام همم في همم
في بريطانيا وهو همم رقم كبير وبالتالي هم
يقولون بان مطالبهم برفع الاجور يتماشى
يعني او همم هو همم يعني يتماشى مع نسبه
التضخم الموجوده في البلاد وهمم الاسعار
همم يعني ارتفاع الاسعار بشكل عام في
البلاد طبعا ايضا من اعتراضات النقابات
على هيئه رفع الاجور وهي هيئه المستقله
المسؤوله عن رفع الاجور يقولون بان هذه
الهيئه تعمل ضمن همم يعني همم تخصص او ما
ما
توجه له الحكومه وبالتالي هي يعني تحت
السؤال ربما هذه الهيئه كيف توصي برفع
الاجور طبعا ك- نعم نحن نعلم بان النقابات
كل نقابه كان لها عرض مختلف من الوزارات
متوسط رفع الاجور المعروض بين اربعه الى
خمسه بالمئه ولكن انا تقول بان هذا همم
تقوم بان هذه النسبه غير غير مناسبه ومن
يعني هم يطالبون برفع نسبه الاجور بنسبه
تتساوى مع نسبه التضخم والتي يعني هي 10%
في في بريطانيا شكرا لك من لندن المراسله
العربيه اعرب عبد الحق
الامن العام لحلف الناتو
حضر خلال زيارته الى اليابان من ان الصين
تبني قواتها العسكريه بشكل كبير وتؤكد
قوتها في المنطقه
دون اي شفافيه انها تحاول تاكيد سيطرتها
على بحر الصين الجنوبي وتهديدات تايوان
تحاول ايضا السيطره على البنيه التحتيه
الحيويه
تفاصيل صادمه مشاهدينا كشف عنها الادعاء
العام في المانيا عن جريمه هزت الشارع في
شهر اغسطس الماضي حيث تواجه فتى المانيه
من اصل عراقي تهمه القتل العمد بعد ان
استدرجت فتاه لها ملامح تشبه ملامحها
وقتلتها بعشرات الطعنات من اجل تلفيق خبر
وفاتها
[موسيقى]
قتلت فتاه تشبهها لتلف تقع خبر وفاتها
جريمه هزت الشارع الالماني في اغسطس
الماضي لكن الادعاء العام
كشفت تفاصيل صادمه
2022 المانيا
من اصول عراقيه
لكن الصدمه جاءت في اليوم التالي بعد
تحليلات الحمض النووي تبين ان الجثه تعود
لفتاه اخرى واسمها خديجه تشبه كثيرا
الفتاه المفقوده التي عثرت الشرطه عليها
لاحقا واحتجزتها على ذمه التحقيق
وفق الشرطه فان المتهمه رتبت وفاتها
المزوره وقررت الاختفاء بسبب مشاكل عائليه
تواصلت المتهمه مع العديد من النساء
اللواتي يشبهنها عبر تطبيق انستغرام
توصلت المتهمه ما عدد من الفتيات اللواتي
كانت لديهن ملامح وتشبهها وقع لاختيار على
فتاه ذات اصول عربيه عمرها 23 عاما
اقنعتها بضروره لقائهما مقابله وعودا
زائفه لم توضح الشرطه تفاصيلها
بعد اللقاء
استدرجت المتهمه والصديق اخر لها الضحيه
الى غابه وطعنها عشرات المرات بهدف تلفيقه
خبر وفاتها
فاضل لي ازمه التعليم التي تشهدها
افغانستان منذ عوده طالبان فبلا سقف ولا
جدران شاب افغاني يبدا مشروع عن تعليميه
تطوعيا للاطفال في الساحات العامه للضواحي
الشرقيه للعاصمه الافغانيه كابول لسد
الفراغ التعليمي في المنطقه التي تخلوا من
المدارس الحكوميه والاهليه مراسل العربيه
زار المدرسه حيث يجلس التلاميذ على وحل
الشتاء تحت درجه حراره تصل الى 20 تحت
الصفر والتقى بالتلاميذ وبمؤسس المدرسه
يحرصوا عرفان الله على الحضور يوميا لفصله
الدراسي رغم اعاقته ورغم برد كابل القارس
[موسيقى]
في هذا البرد نعم الا تشعر بالبرد اشعر به
كثيرا ومع ذلك اتيت نعم
في هذا البرد القارس وعلى الارض وفي اوحال
يجلس هؤلاء الاطفال ليتعلموا محبه العلم
تعني كما يقولها هؤلاء الاطفال
لا توجد في هذه المنطقه الواقعه في
الضواحي الشرقيه للعاصمه كابول مدرسه
حكوميه ولا اهليه ولهذا يضطر الاطفال
لتحمل هذه الصعاب للحصول على قدر من العلم
ناتي الى هنا للدراسه والتعلم فان التعليم
يفيدنا في مستقبلنا
الذي بدا هذا المشروع التعليميه يقول ان
الوضع الاقتصادي الصعبه لا يسمح له ولا
لاهالي المنطقه بتقديم خدمات تعليميه افضل
لهؤلاء الاطفال
الى 40 مقاطعه من مقاطعات البلد ويشاركني
20 من الشباب
هؤلاء الاطفال بنينه وبنات يواصلون
دراستهم من اجل بناء مستقبلهم وذلك على
الرغم من صعوبه الظروف التي يتعلمون فيها
حيث لا تقف يقي البرد في هذه الايام التي
تصل الدرجه البروده خلالها في كابول 20
درجه تحت الصفر عبد الاله نادر العربيه
كابول
الشماليه التي دمرتها الفيضانات مما تسبب
في تعطل الخدمات هذا ولقيه اربعه اشخاص
مصر معاهم في الفيضانات والانهيارات
الارضيه التي ضربت مدينه اوكلا منذ الجمعه
وسطها طول الامطار القياسي
الى العناوين
واشنطن تستعد لتزويد بسلاح بعيد المدى
للمره الاولى قادره على استهداف العمق
الروسي
لتطويل الاسلحه داخل ايران ولا يستبعد
استخدام القوه
المرصاد ايران وحزب لا تستنفر على حدود
سوريا ولبنان ومحيط دمشق
دمتم في امان الله
[موسيقى]